est-ce que vous connaissez sa date de
naissance Guy
là vous allez vraiment me causer des
ennuis
[Musique]
bonsoir
alors vous êtes disons-le tout de suite
le mari de Madonna vous êtes anglais et
à part ça vous faites des films vous
avez fait arnaque film et botanique un
des trois films les plus rentables du
cinéma anglais vous avez fait Snatch
avec Brad Pitt et Benicio Del Toro vous
avez fait à la dérive en 2001 qui malgré
Madonna mérita bien son titre et vous
revenez avec votre quatrième film qui
s'appelle revolver alors dans ce film on
trouve Jason Statham qui est votre
acteur fétiche qui est un ancien
plongeur olympique vous avez découvert
dans une rue de Londres et qui jouait
dans vos deux premiers films ensuite il
a joué avec Tom Cruise dans collatéral
et dans le transporteur dont le numéro 2
est fait un carton en box-office
américain en ce moment on trouve aussi
dans votre film André Benjamin qui est
le leader de Outkast et reliotta qui a
été immortalisé parce corses dans Les
Affranchis on trouve aussi Viny Pastor
qu'on a vu dans les sopranos
et pourtant malgré ce casting
prestigieux gagne il était très
difficile pour vous de monter ce film
vous avez mis deux ans à monter ce film
c'est exact
au moins un an pour faire mes films mais
là
l'idée a été un petit peu plus compliqué
pour ce film là les choses étaient un
peu plus compliquées parce qu'il
s'agissait de jouer sur la confiance de
pouvoir jouer là-dessus justement et
donc il m'a fallu un petit peu de temps
pour arriver à mettre les choses en
place finalement c'est Luc Besson qui
vous a aidé
le concept d'emblée et donc il a été
tout à fait content de vouloir
m'accompagner sur ce projet sans
réticence donc il m'a apporté des fonds
il m'a permis de d'aller de l'avant
alors voilà le pitch du film c'est
l'histoire d'un jeu et comment on gagne
à ce jeu plus clairement c'est un
arnaqueur qui veut se venger d'un autre
arnaqueur qui l'envoyait en prison et
qui pour ça va utiliser deux arnaqueurs
dans cette arnaque c'est que toute cette
arnaque comprend un petit peu tout
ce qui est publicité tout ce qui est
d'ordre juridique tout repose sur cette
idée d'une arnaque et en fait c'est une
arnaque et qui est tout à fait légale et
donc on se rend compte que ça pose pas
vraiment un problème c'est simplement
qu'il y a une manipulation plus ou moins
d'une partie de notre cerveau qui ne se
rend pas compte qu'elle est manipulée
alors c'est un concept intellectuel qui
est enrobé dans un film de gangster en
fait c'est du mental mais divertissant
oui effectivement j'ai ma pensée que
c'est divertissant mais dès lors qu'il
s'agit de jouer sur la confiance des
gens et bien il faut jouer sur
l'intellect aussi il y a eu une
expression utilisée par les arnaqueurs
c'est le fait qu'il faut pas tellement
être futé pour être un arnaqueur mais il
faut simplement être rusé donc c'est
l'illusion que l'on donne qu'on est
qu'on est fuité qu'on est rusé et donc
mais en fait on se rend compte que c'est
que de la poudre aux yeux et finalement
il n'a pas il faut pas vraiment être une
lumière pour faire quelques disparaître
quelqu'un par exemple il faut simplement
être magique
alors vous avez déclaré je suis fasciné
par les ruses et les escroqueries et
celles-ci consiste à piéger les gens en
s'appuyant sur leur cupidité
de ruse dont je parlais tout à l'heure
effectivement il est toujours impossible
d'arnaquer quelqu'un qui est honnête
parce que toute ruse repose justement
sur cette idée que on va on va y gagner
et donc ça marche comme ça
mais c'est pas moi qui établit les
règles c'est comme ça en fait aussi il
faut dire que vous avez été obligé de
quitter l'école à l'âge de 15 ans et que
vous avez été très rapidement en contact
avec la dure réalité du monde vous avez
fait comment pour vous retrouver en
prison
comment est-ce que j'ai fini en prison
parce qu'en fait je n'ai jamais mis les
pieds en prison les journalistes
français vous disent que vous êtes allés
en prison
oui apparemment c'est le cas oui
je pourrais toujours imaginer une
histoire si vous le souhaitez je
pourrais inventer quelque chose d'assez
divertissant des marrant pourquoi pas
allez c'est parti je vais vous inventer
quelque chose alors pourquoi vous êtes
allé en prison
dans le sud de Londres j'étais le seul
anglais dans le quartier dans cet aile
les autres c'était des gens de confiance
j'ai passé 7 ans sur place j'étais pris
entre quelqu'un entre qui en qui je
pouvais vraiment avoir confiance à ma
gauche et d'un autre côté j'étais à côté
d'un quelqu'un qui était très fort en
échec la mettre en échec et j'étais pris
entre ces deux personnes et j'ai appris
arnaquer les gens ça c'est le film je
l'ai vu quand vous avez quitté l'école à
15 ans vous avez fait quoi alors
j'ai passé 7 ans en prison comme vous le
savez
non j'ai fait un peu tous les petits
boulots manuels qu'on peut faire ici ou
là j'ai travaillé comme ouvrier j'ai
porté des briques j'ai mangé une
histoire peut-être à vous raconter en
fait
j'ai creusé des trous pour les systèmes
de des égouts j'ai fait un
vous n'allez pas en prison c'est pas
trop ce que vous avez fait mais à 25 ans
vous réagissez et là vous entrez dans
une société de production comme garçon
de thé en Angleterre Timan
oui ensuite faites des clips vous faites
des publicités et vous faites des films
avec Matthew Vosne alors vous êtes très
fort tous les deux parce que vous vous
avez épousé Madonna lui il a épousé
Claudia Schiffer c'est bien c'est un
concours à la base
à Paris
si c'était un concours je veux pas vous
le dire en tout cas
quel est votre secret à tous les deux je
sais pas si un secret en fait vous
trouvez une femme qui vous intéresse et
vous l'épouser tout simplement ça a
l'air on dirait que la formule
fonctionne finalement je je crois pas
que c'est beaucoup plus compliqué que ça
n'allait pas chercher midi à 14h donc
vous épousez Madonna à l'an 2000 vous
dites que vous vous en foutez un peu
d'être traité de Monsieur Madonna
finalement ça vous embête pas beaucoup
vous dites c'est un peu inévitable
je pense que c'est assez inévitable
effectivement que au bout du compte on
est un nom associé parce que il est
absolument impossible de se déplacer
sans que le temps centre de gravitation
soit le monde de Madonna et non et non
moins alors vous avez eu un enfant avec
Madonna qui s'appelle Rocco pourquoi
vous appelez Rocco c'est en voyant son
sexe
on dit que Madonna porte sur elle un
quartz rose qui favorise la fécondité
c'est ce qu'on appelle la lithothérapie
c'est-à-dire le soin par les pierres on
a vu ça la semaine dernière est-ce que
c'est vrai
mais bon je ne suis que son mari
finalement on dit aussi vous allez nous
dire qu'elle prend des produits
fertilisants à importer des Indes par le
professeur gorille Motta c'est vrai ça
c'est très intéressant mais là encore je
ne suis que son mari bien on va voir ce
que vous savez sur Madonna on va faire
un Madonna quiz
est-ce que vous connaissez le vrai nom
de Madonna
avec quel chanteuse Madonna a-t-elle un
ancêtre canadien en commun
a-t-elle un ancêtre canadien en commun
Céline Dion
est-ce que vous connaissez sa date de
naissance Guy
là vous allez vraiment me causer des
ennuis
non tu la connais toi le 12
le 16 août 58
ah ça c'est une question intéressante
combien d'argent avait Madonna quand
elle a débarqué à New York
40 dollars 35
mais c'est super fort
de quel chanteur est pour quelle chanson
Madonna a-t-elle été la choristes
Patrick
son premier tube en 84 c'est quoi
holiday
dans recherche Suzanne désespérément
fait-elle pleuré une statue d'un sang
noir
de quel film beautiful stranger est-il
la bande originale bravo
où s'est déroulé son concert de 89 quand
elle jette sa culotte au public en
France bien sûr au parc de Sceaux
quand même
combien d'albums a-t-elle vendu
approximativement
30 millions 70 + 100 +
pourquoi Madonna a-t-elle été
hospitalisée cet été
quand elle est tombée de son cheval
quelle est la taille de Madonna
five
bravo 1m64
il commence combien Madonna était-elle
classé au Top 100 des femmes les plus
sexy du monde dans Playboy
35e
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu